oh god oh no I don't want to cook I'm
not gonna go any quicker they say no to
you I say we say no to dancing I want my
baby they're stupid when I became a dad
I made a choice to support my daughter
screams Alex thinks we can afford
tuition and we can't fifty million
dollars thousand honey oh we don't have
the money she can't go to college sure
you go lie that's what parents do
because otherwise the kids are gonna
realize it we don't know what we're
doing
welcome I have a way for you guys to
make four years tuition in one month
underground Kathina check out due to
this map you're 40 years old and you go
to jail for 20 years how old are you
when you get out 90 no hundred I need to
find some scratch paper I can figure it
out you want to make money like Vegas
you gotta look like Vegas
he's got a nail salon massages you're
never gonna believe what's in this next
room is it a strip club that kid a kid's
11 he's a fantastic DJ drop that beat
[Music]
your mother and I will be working late
every night if they feel like the
Alliance you love you so much I'm so
proud of you but you need to shut up
what did you say how hard being a parent
this you're going on with those big
little bet on a friend fighting work as
we know we've heard a fun place awesome
or pretty good in there they both make
the same anime class at the Y D daughter
I don't know why I love me so much are
those women sunglasses no there tell you
I feel like a badass [ __ ] I'm not gonna
tell my daughter she can't go to college
but we was ordered to a life of crime
guys we've got a problem
we got to send a message like dinero
casino you think you can cheat us what
are you guys gonna do about it anyway
well I'm so scared
do you know how hey tell your friends
that they messed it up you're gonna get
you